the Cardassians are killing us with  cuteness and love that look at this  photo of Kim Kanye north and Saint  strutting down the streets of New York  City North giving a silly smile and st.  looking just too sweet Kim instagrams  the paparazzi photo captioning it quote  I love my family and we love Kim's look  these days she is truly more gorgeous  and more fit than ever a source close to  Kim tells ET quote she has been working  out really hard Kim has had a trainer  for years but only recently realized  that was half the battle she works out  really intensely and watches everything  she eats it was really tough for me our  source says Kim goes heavy on cardio and  is strict about staying away from carbs  though she does allow herself the  occasional cheat day